is this really happening yes my love
it's really happening
getting ready to have kids can be a
roller coaster ride so much changes in
such a short amount of time
that it can seem like you've barely
adjusted to one life-altering event
before the universe throws another one
your way
now imagine you're a reality bending
many human married to a sentient android
trapped in an american sitcom
where those life-changing events are
condensed down from nine months to
one day that is one division episode
three and this
is at canada's nerd alert
[Music]
carlos here there will be a light
sprinkling of spoilers in this video but
i want to focus on the possibilities
of what could actually be happening in
good old west view so
stay with me now do you think they know
it's my fault
our neighbors well yes with all the
close calls we've been having it seems
the people of west view are always on
the verge of discovering our secret
in this episode more so than the first
two we see the glitches in the matrix of
this
groovy suburban life
hey hub i think you might have taken my
head strumming a little too far there
old chump
so i have small towns you know
so hard to escape
you're on lockdown huh i feel you and in
the midst of all that
wanda is having a magical pregnancy
literally like they go from surprise
we're having a baby to go get the doctor
it's happening now
faster than you can say you didn't see
that coming and speaking of pietro it
may have been a while since we've seen
him on screen but his memory is very
much alive to wanda
as the mention of his name is enough to
break the spell these people are under
it's a moment in the episode to me at
least that really exposes that wanda
knows
much more than she is letting on he was
killed by ultron
wasn't he
what did you say now one of the big
questions i have and you probably have
too
is exactly how much control wanda has
over what's happening in west view
we've seen that she can rewind and erase
events that she doesn't like
change the environment around her and
can even completely expel
people from this reality like she did
with geraldine
more on that one later up until this
point we've been led to believe that
wanda and vision are somehow trapped in
this situation
what if that's not the case what if
wanda is a willing participant here
all she's wanted since she envisioned
fell in love is to live a life together
away from the conflicts
that define the world of the avengers
however
in the reality we know vision is very
much dead and no you don't need to roll
that clip again we've seen it a thousand
times oh
no you're doing it nope there it is
after that tragedy and the pain and fury
she felt
wouldn't wanda do anything to get vision
back according to paul bettany there's a
plan
for a mid-credits scene in avengers end
game where wanda would see the lifeless
body of vision in a drawer of some sort
so
i mean he's still got to be around
somewhere what if
following the events of endgame wanda
met someone who offered her a way to
bring vision back
so they could have their fairytale life
together but as we've all learned from
like every fairy tale ever perfection
comes at a price
in the comics those twin bundles of joy
are pieces of the soul
of mephisto ruler of marvel's version of
hell
well one of their versions of hell the
other one is watching iron man 21 loop
for 24 hours straight am i right
come on tony come on do you know you
want to just keep
the suit i know it has a filtration
system you could drink that water
so what if wanda made a deal with
someone that will unbeknownst to her
use her newborn babies to bring the lord
of lies
into the mcu fan theories have been
leaning towards
mephisto being a big part of marvel's
next phase for a while now
there's even this cool easter egg in the
trailer for loki
the scarlet witch making a deal with the
devil to have the life she's always
wanted
that's a nice hook right there where's
geraldine
oh she left honey
she had to rush home and what about
geraldine and the other neighbors
the presence of the clandestine
organization sword sentient weapon
operation response division
has been heavily hinted at in every
episode
given that we know she's actually monica
rambo and has a connection to captain
marvel
there's a pretty big chance geraldine is
an agent of sword
may be sent to snap wanda back to
reality or keep an eye
on the newly resurrected vision in fact
my guess is that we've got a
neighborhood
full of a mix of sword agents and other
shady figures
all under wanda and west views spell
or maybe everyone's a scroll i don't
know maybe at the end it'll be revealed
that wanda's been a mutant this whole
time and
ian mckellen as magneto will like float
in demanding to see his grandkids or
something
well that's it for now did you like the
episode are you ready for people to like
fight each other and blow things up
let's talk about in the comments and
i'll see you next time
[Music]
too high is that too high for right here
how about right here
how about right there not
there is this i'm imagining that there's
a box here
watch it right here i wonder what the
what the thumbnail will be